un soltero que busca el amor conocer a
cinco posibles parejas estoy en esto por
amo estoy en esta para mí estoy en esto
para mí estoy en esto por estoy en este
programa aquí está la trampa algunas de
ellas mienten y tratan de ganar el
premio podrá nuestro soltero eliminará
las buscadoras de oro y encontrar una
verdadera pareja o se arriesgará esto es
amor o dinero
[Música]
estén emocionadas
este es el guapísimo soltero hola
hola soy y tengo 24 años soy de grow
city ohio soy un cineasta actor y un
niño de corazón impresionante que buscas
en una pareja busco a alguien que pueda
divertirse tanto como yo vaya donde vaya
si voy al supermercado por leche vamos a
estar allí por dos horas bien debajo de
sus asientos ustedes tienen sobre sí
marcadores pueden agarrarlos y escribir
si están en esto por amor o por dinero
una vez que lo escriban lo guardan y no
pueden cambiar su respuesta
tienes esperanza y tengo esperanza pero
soy soy crédulo esa es una de las cosas
más importantes y si todas dicen la
verdad por eso sigue soltero
probablemente hola chicas
la primera ronda donde van a dar su
primer impresión tienen 10 minutos a
partir de
ahora
estoy decepcionado con ella porque me
mintió me dijo que va estar a mi lado
todo el tiempo
110 necesita un ritmo esto es como algo
muy general empecemos con un hecho
divertido háblame de la cosa más extraña
sobre ti de acuerdo puedo mover mi
barbilla sin mover mi mandíbula y no
quiero hacer esto ante la cámara puede
que sea capaz de hacerlo es esto
eso podemos hacerlo mis días
me pagan por hacerla durante los veranos
eso es genial genial estuvo mucho mejor
de lo que pensaba bien dijiste que
querías a alguien que se divirtiera y
pasará un buen rato y yo tengo esto que
dice me apunto
genial ahora si alguien quiere ir a
algún sitio les dices yo me apunto
literalmente verdad el fin de semana
pasado me gustan los aviones que caen a
200 millas por hora
ahora
mismo de nuestro futuro si salimos
flechas puedes ver qué sucede sin ti en
realidad tengo formación profesional en
ballet clásico empezamos así estaremos
un split split hazlo ahora tengo que
estirarme
[Risas]
la flexión
alta espera tienes que confiar en mi
formación
en el suelo
cómo te sientes me siento bien los 10
minutos pasaron volando parece que les
gustas te crees que algunas están por el
dinero alguna sospecha no sé si puedo
decir y decidir si alguien lo es tal vez
estabas muy ocupado con los estudios ya
que estás listo para eliminar a dos de
estas hermosas mujeres sabes con quién
te quedarás
olvidé la siguiente parte ahora estoy
triste y nosotros también los dicho esto
tienes que eliminar todos hermosas y
ágiles
[Risas]
si la señal es raro pero
lo siento encantada de conocerte fue un
placer conocerte
cuando dijiste que quería alguien que
fuera más divertida y espontánea no sé
pensé que congeniamos un poco más pero
no sé no fue así lo siento
no estás bien lo siento sí sí al sentir
ese rechazo me pregunte cuál fue mi cara
estaba repitiendo la y pensé está bien
esta es la segunda ronda en la que se
llegará a conocer a sus posibles parejas
un poco más estás listo si tendrás cinco
minutos con tu potencial pareja y luego
debo cerrar la ronda o cuentas que
pelarlas como una banana de donde soy
cuentas no pregunta sobre bananos todos
gustan los bananos listos los demás
gusto conocerte
es un placer vimos un avión en la última
toma y pensamos que eras tú volando
sobre nosotras y me asomé a ver por unos
segundos
de nuevo soy sofi de nuevo sofía sophie
sí con ch
no sé si es importante pero soy virgo
vamos a hablar de eso porque estoy estoy
bastante eso me encanta si no me
emociono que dijeras eso porque siento
que es algo que alguien normalmente
guardaría en secreto y
ahora trabajo como instructora de vuelo
le enseño a las personas a volar pero
hago acrobacias de competición hago
algunas vueltas y espirales básicas
yo yo no hago eso cuando entras al auto
dime qué es lo primero que he
reproducido todo el álbum de olivia
rodrigo porque es fantástico pero mis
doctores son bon iver es mi favorito de
siempre haier es que yo te hijos
si soy un nerd me gustan mucho los
zombies star dance y demás siempre lo re
primo porque mi padre solía decir que
nadie quiere hablar de esas cosas si
suelo salir con camisetas gráficas bien
leo muchos cómics y yo solía ver anime
debía decir esas cosas y mi vida en esos
usaba las camisetas y me sabía todos los
temas
hola qué tal fue la segunda ronda la
verdad es que disfruté mucho de la
segunda ronda me gustó hablar con ellos
disfrutaste pelando la banana ya puedes
distinguir a las mentirosas es que sigo
bien voy a ser sincero sigue olvidando
esa parte pero abre los ojos no quiero
ir que rompan el corazón debo llegar al
fondo de la panamá de la mañana
antes de terminar la banana si tienes
que eliminar a una persona de acuerdo se
divirtieron con zac lo hicimos nos
parecía muy natural fue muy divertido me
gusta más esto que enfrentarme a cinco
personas a la vez si eso es válido es
mucho bueno están a punto de ser dos
zach tienes que eliminar a una chica
sabes quién será
sí
odio esto odio esto por igual
a sophie
lo siento sé que tenemos el ph y el ch
pero complacer
a dios
no intento tomármelo como algo personal
ni nada por el estilo pero espero que
pase lo que pase sea para bien en esta
tercera ronda zach de ver a intimar más
con su posible pareja zach estás listo
para hacer carteles pelar de sábana un
poco más solo un poco más podría ser una
banana madura si y no quiere yo le gusta
eso por lomos o si es como muy bien
bueno tienes diez minutos para salir con
estas damas y yo estaré allá diviértete
desorden hasta el sofá bienvenidas al
rincón de zack bienvenidas a mi sala de
estar
la verdad es bastante cómodo y no sé
cómo sentarme y esto es por defecto creo
que sin importar el sofá si es cómo te
sientes si 110%
impresión así que tenemos que estar muy
cerca muy bien esto es genial
tienes alguna pregunta
[Música]
una pregunta profunda podría ser la
entiendo
espacio personal te gustaría aquí
gracias muy bien perfecto no voy a
mentir solo porque no sabía cómo
reaccionar estaba como tienes algún
miedo al entrar en las relaciones el
factor de la dedicación es importante
para mí siento que es algo con lo que
lucho un poco porque una vez que me
gusta alguien tiendo a dedicarle tiempo
a
pensar en cuántas relaciones has estado
he estado en dos series solo por cinco
relaciones seria también soy bastante
reservada así que creo que me cierro a
las personas con bastante facilidad
incluso sólo he tenido dos relaciones o
no sé cómo me acabo lugar aquí realmente
no conozco a nadie y dijiste que hace un
mes que estás aquí no sí sí
te han engañado alguna vez sí en serio
sí cómo fue porque no me gusta eso
fue mi primera relación y por eso fue
algo duro si definitivamente me afectó
mucho tengo problemas de confianza me
preocupe si no yo siento que estoy igual
porque a mí también me engañaron y esas
cosas eso tiene repercusiones y es que
literalmente te afectará por lo que sea
por el tiempo que sea porque no quiero
hacer pasar a alguien por eso nunca si
siento que si no es
lo siento espera lo siento pero después
de eso si bien me alegro de hablar
gracias por venir a este sofá sí gracias
por recibirme
cómo te ha ido me fue bien conocer los
miedos de alguien y esas cosas sobre las
relaciones o por lo que han pasado creo
que es una parte importante si sigues
adelante sonriendo te inclinas por
alguna chica en concreto y si todas
nuestras interacciones han sido muy
relajadas y distendidas en el sentido de
como si estuvieras hablando un amigo
crees que tu elegida está por amor o por
dinero
voy a ser honesto la verdad siento que
ella es la que tiene potencial para
estar por el dinero
zach vas a tener que usar tu corazón
gordo y elegir con quién quieres ir a
otra cita recuerda ambas pueden estar en
esto por amor o por dinero o pueden
estar una por amor y la otra por dinero
sí
quiero tener una cita contigo
[Risas]
lo siento mucho está bien me iré
muy bien
creo que me fue bastante bien no gane ni
nada pero creo que me abrí camino e hice
lo mejor que pude y es que ibas a ganar
más o menos y sentí que teníamos buena
conexión en el sofá
es hora de averiguar si ashley estaba en
eso por amor o por dinero
crees que fuiste capaz de descubrir sus
verdaderas intenciones al ver tal vez tú
crees que tomó la decisión correcta no
no bueno esto es amor o dinero aquí
tienes el sobre para revelarlo escogiste
acuerdo
[Música]
dinero
quiero decir no hay que cortar a los
chicos no puedo pedir su número no
pueden pedir sus redes sociales de
acuerdo acompaña la salida lo siento
mucho entonces yo solo yo fuera dinero
sobre mí o algo así porque el peso sería
genial
jubilee vive intensamente